but i mean how how is the difference
between performing in japan
and say america you know like in america
i feel that when i go on stage it's
it's like a live it's really like a live
thing it's a live experience you're with
your fans you don't
it's nothing is planned you know your
setlist is planned but everything else
is like
uh you know it's got a lot more freedom
yeah it's freedom it's it's up to luck
yeah but in japan i think even the fans
are
very loyal in the sense they really want
you to do your best and they're always
like hoping to do your mouth
[Music]
you know but you know so it's it's the
expectations are completely different i
do love performing independence as much
as i do
love performing overseas as well but at
the same time it's just a different
experience right
yeah i feel that um japan is more based
on like
you know just doing things absolutely to
the best as you can
always being you know just perfect has
anything bad ever happened on stage or
something that you didn't predict
that you kind of just had to deal with
on the spots um
luckily i haven't had huge misses but
i'm always like the fear of mis messing
up
is like here so like it's healthy though
yeah
that's you gotta have that right if you
get too complacent yeah
like you won't you won't do like your
but it does appear as nightmares in my
dreams
you wake up in a cold sweat and you're
like oh what if i [ __ ] up on stage
i i don't know how many times i've had
nightmares where i've
completely like messed up my lyrics
or like i i don't even know my own songs
on stage or like i'm like what am i
doing on stage i don't even know what to
sing i don't know i
my lyrics are completely washed out so i
think
um like somewhere in my head i'm always
like that's
the fear of mine yeah messing up on
stage
so like how is i suppose how has covid
kind of
affected your schedule what'd you like
what what's a day in the life of nano
what would you
what do you do now that you know you
can't go on stage
what's up but like i said though um as a
as like a regular like you know not like
a musician then
i'm a very stay-at-home person yeah this
is very like not
not too different from like comfortable
yeah it's not too different from
your comfort zone but last year in 2020
i had
a lot of um overseas events planned a
lot of my own tour was actually canceled
last
year due to kovitz so um in the music
industry though
kovid has really taken its toll yeah
yeah um
and that's not just me for all the
musicians and entertainment entertainers
out there so
we're we're really struggling in that
sense to be able to find new ways to
um reach out to the audience and to give
back to the audience
even without being able to directly you
know interact with them
so but that's i think a good sort of
start for us yeah because i i assume
that being at home have you had more
time to work on new music
or yeah we've been doing a lot of
creating at home so we're
we're using we're trying to use our
at-home time wisely we're
doing we've you know been creating music
and getting ready for when the time
comes when we're able to
do lives again it's gonna be a hell of a
comeback yeah
hopefully honestly like once like covert
is gone like the amount of concerts that
are just gonna like
pop up out of nowhere everyone's like i
don't have time to go to all these
concerts right yeah i'm just
there's gonna be so many events that i
want to go to when things start opening
up again
my schedule's gonna be so packed but
with
non-work releases yeah yeah i just want
to go to the cinema
you can't even get popcorn it's so sad i
know they're like
you can't you can go to the cinema all
right and you can sit next to other
people now but
that the the reason it used to be to
socially distance with one seat yeah now
you're gonna sit next to each other but
the drawback is you're not allowed to
have popcorn
oh no then i'm not going to i never i
never buy i never buy popcorn yeah
it's part of the theater i hate it
because like it's
because like as you saw earlier i go to
the toilet all the freaking yeah me too
so like when i eat popcorn
i get thirsty so i have to drink but
then i have to go to the toilet and i'm
gonna miss some of the film so i almost
i've learned my lesson now like i have
the bladder of a five-year-old boy
so i i'm just gonna order a little trade
secret
so when we record trash taste we have to
take a break every 30 minutes to reset
the cameras
and me and joey go to the toilet
basically every time
every time during the breaks because we
have a very small bladder
embarrassing that's that's why i know
now it's just like i'm just not gonna
get popcorn anymore i love it like if
if i'm with someone and they have a
bucket of popcorn yeah i'm taking that
[ __ ] popcorn's the one food that i don't
buy for myself but when someone offers
me it
i never say no it's taken
i'm eating all of that wow rude should
we take a break every i do actually need
the toilet